Hello, everyone.
If you think that building a community from
ground zero is very easy, it is not.
It is the most difficult part and especially
if you are not bagged with a brand name.
I have been there.
I have seen that.
Because most of the companies and people prefer
to support the companies which are backed
by the brand names.
A little bit about me.
My name is Neha Sharma.
I'm a full stack developer.
I'm from India.
I am the organizer of JS Lovers meetup group.
One disclaimer, I will be using the meetup
and community word as interchangeable because
my own community is meetup.com, and sometimes
I say meetup and sometimes a community.
And I'm an accidental speaker.
I will show that too.
This is my Twitter handle if you want to follow
and see my tech Tweets, my community Tweets,
you can.
I started my journey with my community JS
Lovers, JavaScript Lovers, three years back.
And after they started living in this.
Best things happen when they are unplanned.
Mostly.
Because JS Lovers was not planned, but I started
it and a most awesome thing happened to me.
Before that, this is my team five years back.
As you can see, I'm the only female.
I was having two troubles at that time.
I moved to a senior level at that time.
And I was not able to see a lot of females
at the senior level.
I was not able to get a mentor for myself
in my city.
The second problem was, we all developers
in my city, we were more focused towards our
job.
We were not into collaboration.
We are not into sharing.
We are our focus is only our job, my little
9 5, apart from that, we were not interested
in anything.
And I started actually saying these things.
Learn something new every day for yourself.
Just not for your company, not for your job,
just for yourself.
So, what I did?
So, I was just going around looking for mentors,
looking for senior females in the tech field
and I was not able to get a single female
in the tech industry in my city.
So, I was just talking to one of my colleagues.
I knew about meetup.com platform.
And I just bounced the idea.
Would you be interested in sharing our knowledge
with the other people who are new in this
IT world?
And my colleague was like, yeah, I can do
it.
Because he was a trained speaker.
So, I said, okay.
On the same day, in the evening, sitting in
a cafe, I built my meetup page.
I picked this domain and my event was up.
And my journey from a developer to a coordinator
was started.
We had one chapter, zero sponsor and no experience
running a community.
I had no idea how I was going to do it.
But after three years, here we are.
Now we have done
[ Applause ]
Sorry.
Okay.
Technical glitch.
Sorry.
So, after three years this is the stats.
We have done more than 55 meetups in just
in my city.
We have more than three chapters in India.
In Delhi itself we have 2700 members.
Out of that, 85% of the people are very active
and we have 25 plus sponsors.
And not only this, we are the first community
who will become the part of the Google Developer
Program from Delhi.
And we are the first, most active community
from India to be a part of that group.
So, yes, it was a very big achievement for
us.
But it was easy?
Not at all.
I was having a full time job.
I was having although I'm not married, but
I have my parents who I have to, you know,
I live with them.
The culture of India is very different.
My first trouble started with my family.
When I told them that this is what I'm trying
to do, my father's reaction was, I told you,
become a teacher after schooling.
But you were like, no, you want to study computers
and everything.
Now you have a stable job.
You are in a group.
Now you want to teach people free of cost
by paying for the venue and everything by
your pocket.
You are stupid.
[ Laughter ]
And I was like, no, dad, it's not like that.
It is not teaching as a job, it's like mentoring
and helping others.
And someday I might fight with my family and
that started.
And every weekend when I'm stepping out of
my home for doing my meetup, I used to have
a big fight with my family.
Why you are doing this?
This is a waste of time.
They are not able to understand.
Not even my family, my friends also used to
make a joke of me.
So, many of my friends started following me
on Facebook because my whole feed was full
of the meetups, tech stuff and everything.
And I was like, okay, whatever.
So, today in the morning when I entered in
the conference area I actually Tweeted, I'm
sorry, I will be shamelessly filling your
feeds with the JSConf Tweets.
Deal with it.
My job problem was that.
But I didn't give up because I knew what I
was going, and I was very focused.
How did we get to this level?
You need to know where you are running the
community, you need to understand the culture.
In Delhi, doing a meetup or event on the weekdays,
it will never work.
Only on the weekends people come out of their
home to attend an event.
For that, you need to do a lot of hard work.
You need no know your members and the tech
industry.
And I started the levels and Angular was just
launched.
People were running behind Angular, they had
no idea they needed to learn JavaScript.
There were a few developers that came to me
and asked, should we just learn Angular in
frameworks, or is it important to learn JavaScript?
At that time, I decided to do the first meetup
on JavaScript, no framework or nothing.
That helped me a lot because there were a
lot of people who just started their career
by a framework and they had no idea about
the basics.
So, whenever you are starting something, please
know your city, your culture, your client.
I was ready for the events, I was ready for
the meetup, but my city was not.
There was not a single place available in
my city where I can have 30 people with a
projector.
I actually struggled two months to get a venue.
And I ended up having my first meetup at a
cafe, which was at a party zone.
And I was like, what?
And that was not even the closest venue.
So, whenever we were doing coding, a lot of
people were coming in and asking, can we get
the table?
And we said this is a closed event.
Area closed.
So, it was very troubling.
But before that, the most troubled part that
have venue is, my parents used to think that
I'm lying because on the weekend I'm going
to such a party happening place.
So, they used to assume that I'm just going
out to, you know, have fun with my friends.
As a result, I have to spend extra money to
record whole sessions to take the pictures
and go back and show my parents, see?
I'm not partying.
I'm actually doing something relevant.
So, this is how the logistics were very tricky
there.
And with the speakers also.
So, for one year we were not able to get an
outside speaker.
Reason?
We were not a brand name.
Developers used to come.
They used to love it, like it, but they were
hesitant to come on the stage and share their
knowledge.
So, nobody.
I became an accidental speaker because of
that because I started giving the sessions
there.
But now after three years, I have so many
speakers sending their slides requesting,
but now I don't have the time to, you know,
bring every speaker on the stage.
So, this is how I never gave up.
When I was not able to get a speaker, I took
that responsibility.
I learned stuff, I stood on the stage and
gave the session.
So, logistics are very important.
You need to work on the logistics.
The first venue, it was at a funny place,
but the best part is, it was very accessible
by public transport.
Because I'm a female and an organizer.
I know every female who is struggling to get
to the venue.
Delhi is not a friendly transport space.
As a female, when I was organizing, I was
already taking care of these things by myself.
Community.
This is the most funny part.
Because when I decided to start the meetup,
I was preparing myself that a lot of people
would be asking tech questions.
But nope.
What is a meetup and community?
And people are filling my messages with, what
are you trying to do?
They were not able to understand is why a
girl on every weekend is doing free meetups
and sharing her knowledge and not charging
anything.
Is she trying to sell something?
Is she going to hire us?
Is there a company behind it?
And I was like, no, my friend.
This is the essence of a community.
This is a community by developers for developers.
I know the thing when I was looking for mentors
and I was not able to get.
I'm helping you out so in the future you will
go out and you will help others.
But from most of the people, it was alien
stuff.
And I was getting random questions around
it.
And one of the questions which I used to get
frequently was, what do you do on meetups?
Because getting an online platform to an offline
event is very tricky.
You need to gain the trust and especially
developers are very hesitant.
They feel very shy that how we will go to
a random place, sit with random people.
Who am I going to talk to?
I got tired of answering this question.
I went ahead and wrote a block.
JS Lovers meetup.
I mentioned each and everything, how I plan
a meetup, do the topics, how I open the registration
form.
When you are coming on the day of the meetup,
you will find someone welcoming you.
They will give out name tags and how this
whole session will go.
What we will solve and after the meetup is
done, how to do the follow ups.
And I put a lot of photos and video of the
meetups.
There was a huge positive response.
A lot of people started coming without asking
questions.
Also, this article is getting shared by members
of the my community when someone is joining.
Be ready, do not hesitate.
Go ahead and write stuff and put it on your
website for your community because you never
know what kind of questions people are coming
with.
Sponsors.
The most interesting and important part of
the community.
We were not lucky.
For one year we were running our meetups with
our salary.
We paid for our food and venue and do the
meetups free of cost.
I didn't have any experience, I have no experience
how I can reach them.
Non branding meetups for the community.
So, let's try the time.
But luckily for us, we got a sponsor.
And, again, the same question, what are you
doing on weekend?
Are you trying to hire people?
Do you have any sort of questions.
And I was explaining a lot of that for working
space.
And they got they were very happy and what
they offered us is you can utilize our space
free of cost.
Then we did our meetup there is.
So, this is how we got our first venue sponsor.
After that, we got Microsoft as our official
sponsor.
That was a big break for us because Microsoft
was our first corporate sponsor.
They came up with the venue, food, as well
as speakers.
And this is how we have to get a sponsor.
First is food and venue, and second is knowledge
partners.
They can send their speakers to send knowledge.
One thing I learned out of that, sponsors
are a relationship.
For me, it is not that if someone is sponsoring,
I will say yes.
I first evaluate what value they can add.
What value I can add to them.
Only then do I say yes.
Because JS Lovers is a community dedicated
to developers only.
So, if some sponsor is coming to sell something
or pitch something, I just say no.
Unless and until it is something valuable.
Same with me, if I'm not able to add any value
to their community, my community, I say no.
So, if you can going to pick any sponsor,
please pick is very carefully.
It is very important.
Because your members are very smart.
They will understand that you have a paid
sponsor standing on the stage.
So, you need to be very careful.
I have said no to many sponsors.
And I don't regret because I know because
of that there is trust of my members.
A few of the sponsors are here.
Out of that, Amazon.
And we keep doing a lot of swags.
And people get hooked to us.
But it is not that every time they will get
swag.
This is the most tricky part.
This is a surprise factor.
If you are coming to our meetup this month,
you might get, or you might not get.
This is always a surprise factor.
Collaborations.
Collaboration was very, very important.
If you try to survive on your own, you will
not go a long way.
You need to learn from and with others.
It's very important.
So, when I started JS Lovers after a few months,
there were a lot of people who used to attend
our workshop from the first event.
And when they said, are you interested in
learning something apart from JS?
And they said, yes.
So, we did an IoT workshop and got good response.
I asked for the feedback.
Now they feel happy because they have a skill
apart from the primary skill and they enjoyed
that.
And I analyzed and saw, yes, it is important,
if I'm a developer, IoT, it is fun.
You never know what is your hobby.
I started doing collaboration with other communities
and other technologies.
And this helped my members as well as me too
as an organizer because I learned what other
organizers are doing, how they are doing.
So, I was missing the biggest thing, which
is code of conduct in my community.
While I was doing the collaboration, one of
the organizers actually shared with me that
you should have a code of conduct in your
community.
Because if someone is actually trouble you,
that code of conduct can help you a lot.
And then I said, oh, yes.
I forgot.
And this is how I learned it.
By doing the collaboration.
By meeting new organizers.
So, please, if you are getting the opportunity
of doing collaboration, do it.
I'm not scared.
A lot of people come to me and say, you are
a JavaScript community.
Why are you doing meetup on this?
Because my members are asking for it.
They wanted to learn and grow.
Feedback.
Always, always ask for the feedback because
this is what I believe, feedback is your next
steps.
If JS Lovers is able to come through three
years just because of we worked on feedback.
If I'm not getting a feedback, I feel I'm
doing literally a very wrong thing.
Developers are very shy.
Especially in Delhi, it's very hard to get
feedback.
It's very hard to make them talk.
So, the first thing is language.
Most of the developers, they assume that their
English is not good and all that.
So, what as an organizer and speaker is we
make them comfortable in speaking in their
native language.
It's fine if you don't know English, but we
know your native language.
And we actually promote that.
Let's have a meetup in native language.
And then I ask for the feedback.
I never ask feedback in data questions.
I also ask with options.
At least the audience will reply.
Do you like the location?
Yes or no.
Do you like having an event here?
Do you like the food?
And I end the session with the open invite,
if you like this event, please spread the
information about the event.
If you don't, please write me.
I will look into it.
You need to ask for feedback.
Feedback will help you a lot and grow.
As a result, initially when people were not
open to write their feedback on the meetup
page, event page.
Now they are openly going and sharing the
feedback on social media.
This is how you have to do it.
There would be the moment when people are
not doing it, but you need to push them.
And just keep doing it.
It's not like this that everything is working
for them.
Nope.
A lot of things, a lot of places where I fail,
my ideas fail, and a lot of things fail.
A few of the cases, a lot of meetups.
The idea was to have a lot of meetups and
have a lot of members joining us.
As a result, we were doing three to four meetups
in a month.
It was so hectic for the organizers and the
members.
Because everyone was busy Monday to Friday
in their job.
And Sunday coming for the code lab is very
tricky.
So, this doesn't work.
So, what we started doing is, one meetup once
in a month.
That's it.
And that actually helped us a lot.
Now people started looking for that one meetup
in a month to meet us.
Building the best team.
Running our community at such scale is very
tricky.
It was just me and my co organizer and we
used to have full time jobs also.
So, it's like a crazy job.
We were doing two jobs.
I was not able a build a team because we were
looking for the best people.
And as a result, I was just ending up following
with them.
But after a few months I realized I should
look for the self motivated people who understand
what it takes to be a part of the community.
As a result, we are five people who help in
social media, graphics and everything.
They take care of everything and I don't need
to do any follow up or anything.
They just know because they are self motivated
and they know what they want to do.
And this is the most asked question, what's
the group?
People used to put all the code on the WhatsApp.
And I had to drop that group.
You need to be there every time doing moderation
and everything.
So, it was like I'm running an offline community
and also maintaining an online community.
And every time I have to push the discussion
from one place to another.
And I was like, this is not them.
This is what you asked.
You need to run it.
I can't be the organize the main person behind
that.
These two things didn't work for me.
So, I stopped and kept everything on my platform,
which is Meetup.
But the second problem.
In one of the meetups we have a few females
and then there's only me.
Then there are a few females and then, again,
it's only me.
So, I was hoping that a lot of females would
come because a female is the front face.
She is running the show.
She knows all the pain, she has taken care
of everything.
But, no.
This is not happening.
And then I started thinking is it is because
the problem I'm facing with my family, friends
and society.
For them, it is much harder because they are
just coming to attend an event.
They can't explain why they are going for
eight hour just to learn something.
Because in Delhi, most of the parents, the
parents, you have a full set of job, you are
getting the salary.
That's it.
Don't think beyond that.
Don't think about doing something else.
I knew that trouble.
And I was like, what can I do about this?
I need to make sure that those females are
knowing that something is happening, they
are learning and everything.
Meanwhile, there was a girl who attended one
of my workshops.
She reached me on social media.
She said she had some doubts.
And then I started helping her in making blogs
that I think writing blogs and making videos
and everything.
And as a result, after three months I get
to know that she actually built her first
progressive web app.
She presented in college.
Her professor liked it.
She gave a workshop at her college level.
They liked it.
And she also got an internship because of
that.
And she actually messaged me that because
you helped and guided me all through on social
media by doing videos, blogging and everything,
I'm able to do it.
Then I realized, it's fine if you're not coming
to my meetup.
But for me, it would be very wrong if you
are reaching with me for help online and I'm
not doing it.
I keep getting messages from people I have
never met.
I'm sure every speaker gets this.
You don't know me, you have never met me,
but I saw your video and read your blog and
inspired me to do this or that.
That's what the community is.
That's what JS Lovers is doing.
We are helping everyone.
Especially because I'm a girl, sorry.
And everyone who is reaching me on social
media, on my email that we need help and I'm
helping them out.
Guys, if you are a community organizer, if
you are planning to run a community.
It's not just they came into the room and
went; your relationship is done.
It's about support and maintaining them after
that.
Please do it.
It will make a lot of the difference.
As a result, meetup on which my group is,
they actually invited me two months ago to
their headquarters in New York to share my
story.
As well as they also covered my story that
how I do a meetup.
A good thing also happened with me.
I hope this helps you a lot to if you're an
organizer.
You get some tips.
If you are planning, you get an idea how you
have to do it.
The important part is, never, ever give up.
This is my mantra.
You never know who you are inspiring.
Literally never know.
When I started, I didn't know I was helping
so many people.
But when I get messages, I feel so happy that
a small idea of running a meetup, now it's
reached this level.
Thank you, guys.
[ Applause ]